Hey,
what's going on is bill burn is time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I am just checking in on you.
Who's that?
Check aid and argue your can't.
Sorry,
I'm in New York.
You know,
all of a sudden you just going to start doing your little Sinatro vibe.
Um,
Joe,
I'm going out and I'm buying a new pair of fucking sneakers today.
Go Away.
Are going to get you do you to get the Jordan five still?
I don't know what I'm going to get.
You know I'm going to,
I'm getting some old man running sneakers.
I need some workout sneakers.
You know I bought the ones that were on better call Saul for the old ladies that
you guys watched the rest of that series.
Did you see it yet?
Can I ruin it for you?
I'm going to tell you in the last episode and the last scene when the guy says,
okay,
just trying to get all you guys to scamper for your fucking pause buttons.
No,
no,
no.
People literally run out of the room.
People run out of the fucking room.
When you'd start talking about a show,
they haven't seen the last episode yet.
Have they do that?
You know what I mean?
But if you just sit there and you're fucking,
somebody rips a fire,
people just put a fucking shirt over their nose.
Oh,
who did that?
You're literally inhaling air from this guy's ass.
You know?
And that doesn't make it leave the room.
But if,
God forbid,
somebody brings up the last episode of a fucking show,
you haven't seen everybody runs out like the building's on fire.
Yeah.
Um,
it is a perfect,
perfect day in New York City.
The breeze,
dude,
this breeze,
top five breezes ever this breeze.
My top five ever.
That's a very easy thing for,
as you would actually rank his breezes.
Top five reasons ever.
Dude.
I was sitting there,
I had on a pair of Jordan's sexes with the Fucking v Neck with the chain on the
outside over,
over.
Waitress came up to me.
She could barely take my order.
She couldn't,
she couldn't even like she was taking in.
The whole thing was ridiculous.
New Para guests,
jeans over.
Ah,
fuck.
Anyways.
Um,
yeah.
So I'm up in fucking Porchester.
I don't know what Port Chester is.
They know Westchester.
There's east Chester and Alva dentally.
There's port Chester,
which I believe is just Connecticut.
I'm there tonight,
I'm there tomorrow and then I'm there on Saturday.
Okay.
And then I'm done and I'm back.
And uh,
I'll tell you right now,
you have not experienced loneliness till you have a fucking kid and then you
leave my favorite part of the fucking days when my kid wakes up.
You know what I mean?
Cause like they're super fucking rested and they just,
you know,
life hasn't beaten down yet.
They don't have any credit card debt.
Then they'll get some psycho blowing up their phone.
They don't have this shit.
They got to do some fucking receipt.
They have to find,
they got,
they got nothing.
They,
the look of contentment on her face.
You know when you go down,
when you go to give her a kiss,
like she lifts all of her limbs come up
like a baby's ability to do leg lifts.
I don't know how the fuck if I tried to do what she did,
just straight up,
just lift some write up.
I don't get it set.
Ted's suck in their toes.
Evidently I was that flexible at one point.
Tell you that a couple of million miles in the back of the fucking plane.
That'll,
that'll take the infant radar.
You,
that'll take this Flaco right out of your eye.
Um,
that's what I missed the most,
so that I will always face time with my lovely lady and um,
as the best.
It's the best,
but it sucks and I'm on the road,
but I just started here being like,
you know what?
I'm earning money someday.
So when she has to go to private fucking,
uh,
kindergarten for 90 grand a year or whatever the hell it costs because evidently
she goes to a public school,
she's going to get stabbed.
You know what happened?
What happened to the public schools?
Was that the computers?
Is that what it was?
Everybody had to have a tablet,
a laptop,
some sort of interface.
Is that what happened?
And went right through the fighting and all of a sudden we couldn't keep up with
China.
How to fuck his China beaten us the overhead of a fucking billion people alone.
I mean,
we should be like,
we should get everything at a 60% discount over here as far as educating our own
people.
Does it make any sense?
Does any of it make any fucking sense?
Does it make any sense how so many people are fucking struggling out there and
they just keep building these luxury apartments and he's fucking giant goddamn
houses.
Oh,
right.
And they,
oh yeah,
it's money from Russia.
It's Ronnie from China.
It's oil money from the Middle East.
Now listen,
I don't know what to do about China.
I don't know what to do about Russia and I don't know what to do about the
Middle East.
But that's not going to stop me from telling you what to do about all these
things I just ate.
Why is my stomach grumbling?
Um,
he says,
all you gotta do for the Middle East.
Okay.
All we do is we just,
you're fucking,
you embrace solar power.
That's it.
How do we do that?
How do we do that with the oil companies?
If somebody fucking,
it will be,
if we actually went into solar direction,
wouldn't a bunch of planes start crashing that had the leaders of the solar
movement on them?
Yes.
That would definitely happen.
They would definitely take them out.
So what do you do?
This is what you do.
You give the son to the oil people.
Okay,
you draw up a contract and you say the sun is yours.
All right.
Now what are they going to do with the site?
They can't put it out.
They can't touch it.
It'll burn their fucking hands,
but they just make the money off the fucking,
uh,
the solar power.
Okay.
And if they could just somehow handle that,
those people in the Middle East to sitting on a bunch of Goop,
that they can make money off of it or they could just seamlessly fucking walk
away from that Shit.
If I was president,
I would literally give oil companies federal fucking grants to fucking get the
solar thing going.
You guys own the sun.
I would just keep walking.
But you own the sun and they'd be sitting above 4.0 poker stuff for this stuff
with a middle way stove,
dude.
Fuck that stuff.
All right?
You want that stuff?
Is that,
that stuff's like a,
the dub took an Atari.
It's like the Reebok pump.
Nobody gives a shit.
Okay?
This is the new shit.
This is the new shit we're giving you the fucking son,
son.
You understand that you all own the center of the solar system,
all right?
And every fucking little bit a heat that comes off that thing that trickles down
on a mic.
Freckled ball.
Goddamn head.
You own,
you put a fucking meter right on my back.
I don't give a shit,
okay?
And I know what you guys are thinking.
Ah,
built.
This doesn't make any fucking sense.
I don't give a shit.
Let's listen to me.
Hear me up.
You give these people the sun,
you give him the Goddamn son.
All right?
And then what?
What happens over in the Middle East,
this sitting on all of this fucking goop,
alright.
And all of a sudden it's not worth,
it's not worth diddly squat,
okay?
And all of a sudden the fucking,
the bill start piling up.
They don't know what to do.
They start selling their properties over here.
They want to give money to the terrorist groups saying,
oh,
cut the money to do it.
You have fucking bleed them dry.
Then that's it.
And then they go back to doing whatever the fuck they want to do over there.
God forbid they live their lives they way they want to live it over there.
Yeah.
God forbid they're not into Jesus and Starbucks,
God for fucking bid.
They want to walk around and some clothes that are actually functional for the
part of the world they live in.
You just leave them the fuck alone.
And then all they gotta do is just keep driving around in cars and all of that
shit.
So they,
you know,
they'll make a lot less money,
but they won't have us over there going at,
you should do this and you should do that.
We just get the fuck out of there.
And then we're over here,
solar powered everything
right.
Just think about everything you think about your shirt,
solar powered,
everything.
Everything fucking solar powered.
Know what you thinking?
Well Bill,
what happens at night?
You'd go to bed.
What do people do in Alaska during the winter?
We got to get out.
We got again,
I a bad place.
If it's the last thing we ever do,
it's bankrupting us.
It's making it very few people at ton of fucking body.
It is bankrupting us.
We're not going to see,
cannot solve
that shit.
Okay.
Okay,
so now that we know you can't solve it because I said you can't solve it without
doing any research.
Now that now that I've established that as a fact on my own podcast,
the only thing,
other reason to be over there is this sitting on all that goop,
but now we don't need the group,
the group,
the group is on fire.
We don't give a fuck.
Keep it.
Right.
You give the son to the oil companies.
That's it.
Just go total solar power.
You know Jimmy Carter,
that Georgia peanut farmer,
he said it 40 years ago.
He said,
we are addicted to oil.
We've had.
We just kept going and going and going,
and now look at us now.
Look at us now.
Look at US spending all this fucking money over there.
They're giving it to the concept of shooting shit at us,
right?
And then when shooting back at them,
they're making all this money and then they come over and they buy a 50 fucking
thousand square foot house overlooking our shit.
Overlook.
Look in RJ.
Hey,
we overlook you
were up on the hill,
not the other way around.
Huh?
You give them the sun.
Okay.
Oh God,
you guys,
I'm telling you,
I would have to,
I would fucking sell those oil guys.
I would have a meeting under a mountain or wherever the fuck do you meet with
these fucking people that really run shit.
You know,
you're underneath the mountain.
You got this fucking underwater waterfalls and shit.
Right?
There's like these planet of the apes plucking things,
walking or whatever the fuck goes on underneath that thing.
Right?
And you just tell him,
I miss that shit.
Why would I can't,
I can't do a waterfall and my fucking the dude from police academy,
I can't do that.
Sound effects?
Yeah.
Gentlemen.
I came here.
I came underneath this mountain tonight.
Okay.
To keep you the son.
I'm sorry.
I don't have my proper recording equipment here.
I can't,
I can't do my illuminati media.
You give him the fuck him.
The fucking
give them the fucking the ball.
Ball Ball,
ball ball.
That's what I would do.
Instead of going over there talking about evil doors and doors are evil and
fucking this,
that and the other.
Yep.
Pack the whole fucking Shit Up.
That's it.
You pack it all up.
Sent over 10 cargo planes.
You bring the men and women at the allied forces.
You bring them home,
right?
You say you can keep your Google,
you can keep you say,
but I want some of those cool clothes.
I like the clothes they wear over there.
The Jane Open ended one,
Z,
whatever the fuck you call it.
I think those things are cool,
man.
I wish I want,
I want one of those.
Can I buy one of those without offending Muslims?
Could I talk my way out of a beheading if I put one of those on,
just went,
look man,
I'm a chef.
I'm a red head.
It was hot out.
I look,
I look on I,
what am I supposed to do
when they get my face?
You'll blow away.
Um,
that's it.
That's all I wanted to say today.
Give the oil companies this son,
you'd give it to them and then the whole fucking thing is over.
Whatever.
I believe I can fly.
Um,
so I got to get here tonight and I'm going to go,
well,
I'm going to go play some drums,
is a little rehearsal studio down the street.
I'm going to go play my fucking drums for a couple hours.
I was going to go ride around on one of those fucking Citibank fucking banker
bicycles,
but there's never any,
they got like 14 for the whole city.
And then also what kind of an asshole rides a bicycle in a city.
You know what I mean?
What am I in Europe?
How many people die a year in Europe?
Just riding around on bicycles in a fucking city.
So it's fucking cars go by Wa wa we fucking get another ambulance going over to
pick up some fucking,
okay.
Okay.
Six foot,
three inch,
fucking 110 pound European that you could take it out on his bicycle that has a
basket on the front.
MMM.
I liked riding bicycles.
Oh,
you know what?
I watched this documentary called ovarian psychosis.
Right?
How do you not click on that?
I first clicked on this action movie and it was just the same fucking shit.
The one guy who beats the fuck out of everybody.
Nobody ever think they all have guns,
but they never think to use it.
And I was just like,
I've seen this a million times.
It's really loud.
And look at that nice classic car.
They're racking the fucking thing.
I can't watch the ship.
So I shut it off and I saw this thing called a variant psychosis and I was like,
I want,
I got work.
I see what this is about.
It was about some,
uh,
some women in east La,
mainly Mexican who are sick of fucking being scared women and they started their
own group when they ride around these women's only,
uh,
you know,
riding bicycles when there's like a full moon or some shit.
I Dunno.
So I was watching this stuff and of course typical guys look goodwill,
women's,
all we go,
so
does all the bud,
right.
I hate when people act like it's a level playing field,
you know what I mean?
It's like they're having this thing because it's not a level playing field.
One of the women in there was just like,
everything's kind of full fucking men only.
What's your,
it really is when you really look at it.
Okay.
I don't want him to fucking come off as like a complete God damn liberal here.
All right.
But you know,
it really is,
it's,
it's just,
it's there for the taking for you.
When you're a guy,
you know,
not saying you're going to get it.
Okay.
Nine out of 10 people still fail.
That's one thing that feminists don't realize.
You know,
when you listen to them talking about what it's like to be a guy that had this
cartoonish idea of what it's like to be a guy who just show up.
Oh.
And the classic one,
the more you act like a Dick,
the more people respect you.
I love that one.
If a women of a woman does it,
she's considered a bitch.
If a guy does it,
it's like,
yeah,
Tempe ever done a survey,
just asked the general public,
Hey,
if you had your choice between working for somebody nice or working for a
complete fucking asshole who treats you like shit,
which would you pick?
Yeah,
nobody does.
I think the,
when I meet successful people,
truly successful people that get it
successful in there,
personal life and in their professional life,
those people,
I always meet,
their always humble.
There's self deprecating.
They walk into a room,
you want to be around him and they,
they,
they're good at talking to people.
They don't come in like fucking Alec Baldwin in Glengarry Glen Ross.
Um,
that bullshit that men respect a gay,
like they fucking record of fucking,
no,
I don't,
I don't respect anybody.
Like what I see is an insecure asshole who's afraid it's all going to go away by
the African.
Um,
anyway,
so I'm watching this documentary,
check it out.
It's actually really,
you're only gonna get bothered me about the documentary is the way they spelled
psychosis,
ovarian psychos.
It's like,
but you're on cycles.
So why didn't you spell the first half?
Like cycle and the rest like psycho,
you know,
a little wordplay there.
Nothing.
All right.
Anyways,
so I watched it.
It was interesting and actually it's this one woman said in it,
you know,
cause she'd been through all this shit when she was,
uh,
a little girl with their mother and then she had a daughter,
I believe she was at least she had a kid.
She became a mom.
And then her mother said,
well,
now do you at least understand me?
I bet you understand me a lot more.
And she said to her mother,
no,
actually I've never understood you less.
And actually cringed when I,
when I saw that.
And I was just like,
you know,
that's something,
if you feel it,
you don't say to your mom
like,
what do you get out of saying that to you mother?
All you're going to do is devastator and make her feel like she completely
failed as a mom and it
doesn't get you any real estate.
That's something you say to your friend.
Yeah.
And now that I have a kid,
it's just like,
I don't even understand what the fuck my mother did to me.
Even more than you fucking clunky wine coolers and then that's it.
You don't say it to your mind.
We're checking.
Call us.
Um,
I just watched the Schick hydro transformer ad that made those dollar shave club
ads make even more fucking sense.
The blade literally turned into one of those fucking robots.
Yeah.
Why is [inaudible] wagging his finger at me?
Like he just blocked a shot in a mobile one commercial.
Is he out of NBA Money?
Where the fuck did he come from?
I don't know.
Where did he buy one too many fucking gold chains and some shit and he's like
called up his agent or I need to work again.
Was that Schwartzenegger?
I don't know.
I don't have no idea.
Um,
I don't have my ads.
I'll have to read the ad at the end of this fucking thing.
Whenever that,
whenever the fuck that thing comes in,
I have no idea.
Oh,
by the way,
I forgot to bring this up.
Season three of f is for family is going to happen.
Thank you so much to everybody who watched,
we are now I'm breaking stories for season three.
It's animation.
So season three or to come out somewhere in late 2019.
Now we're hoping that we can have it come out.
You know,
we came out May 30th of uh,
this year.
So that's when I'm personally,
that's what I'm shooting for now.
I haven't communicated that to anybody I've worked,
I'm working with.
I'm just assuming that they already know that and,
and if it doesn't happen,
I will just get quiet for no reason around them.
That's the way I was taught to communicate with others while growing up.
Do all the math in your head.
Do not communicate it to anybody and when they don't see it,
the way you see it,
you just stopped talking to people.
That was the way it was done.
And then you just don't talk to him for like three days.
And then,
then when they finally like,
well I guess I'm not going to fucking talk to you again.
You then out of nowhere,
it bring up whatever game happened last night and you start talking about it
like the last three days.
Never fucking happened.
That's the way it was done
when I was growing up.
Um,
hey,
one of these days I'm actually going to fly up to port Chester and helicopter.
I'm trying to convince this guy to put dual controls on.
It's the whole fucking purpose of me going right.
Fly over the George Washington bridge.
I just want to see how you,
uh,
transition through all this fucking commercial airspace where you have JFK,
you have LaGuardia and you have new work.
But I see helicopters all the time going up and down the Hudson Bay.
So there's gotta be some corridor that they're allowed to fly.
Like probably I would guess no higher than like,
I dunno,
they fly it really fucking low,
but I never know if it's like sightseeing,
but I wouldn't think you'd be any higher than a thousand feet
and he just Kinda,
you know,
and then just look out for Sally when he comes to landed
in the Hudson Bay.
Um,
I do know with lax you either transition along the beach at a below one 50 or
you go along supported a boulevard,
which I never do that one.
That one always scares the shit out of me because you look down and there's a
jumbo jet underneath you.
And I always think like,
what if she aborts is landing and just fucking yanks back on the stick.
Then I got this fucking 300 person missile coming right at me and my little
[inaudible],
you know,
you ever see a cheetah running down a baby,
whatever.
That's what it would be like accepted,
see aviation version of that.
And I would be the baby gazelle,
not even a gazelle.
A baby turtle.
How slow is a baby turtle?
Is there anything sadder than watching that documentary?
When those baby turtles try to make it to the ocean and all those fucking
seagulls come down and pick off nine out of 10 of them.
I fucking love turtles.
I had a pet turtle when I was a kid
and um,
used to feed it like dead grass hoppers and shit.
I love this fucking thing.
I love cleaning the tank,
making sure its shell stayed fucking wet and all that so it wouldn't crack.
And uh,
had my little tank set it up.
I fucking love this thing.
I love watching it coming up for air and all that shit.
So one time I went to church because that's what I used to do every Sunday.
Right.
So I went to church with my feet and we baggies.
So we go to church and uh,
I came home
okay.
And the turtle was the way I positioned the rock.
The turtle
had gone head first into the water and it's turtle ass was out of the water.
Okay.
I went over and I picked it up and its head was sunk all the way back.
Intuit's like Shell and its eyes would close and his mouth was open and it
wasn't moving.
Okay.
And I was like,
oh fuck,
it's a dead.
Did it drown?
And I went downstairs and I said,
dad,
it's my turtle dead.
He goes,
yeah,
he's gone.
And I was fucking devastated.
So I took them rather take a brown,
okay,
you know you put your lunch in the Brown,
like lunch bags,
put the turtle in there.
And then I went out in the woods and dug it a little grave and put the marker up
and then that was it.
And then my dad was like,
well,
we'll get you another one,
we'll get you another one.
I was like,
no,
I don't deserve it.
I blame the turtles.
I,
it was my fault.
I set up the fucking
the rocks wrong.
And that was just said,
sag.
I'm saying,
that's it.
That's it.
I'm done.
You know I've done,
I'm not going to kill another fucking turtle.
And it was so weird,
like four days later we were driving down the street and it was a turtle
crossing the street.
This is when there was actually animals,
you know,
before we fucking killed and ate all of them.
You know,
I blamed the food network for that,
you know,
and all these fucking assholes going around eating bizarre foods.
Okay,
I'm in Timbuktu,
Wheaton maggots right now all of a sudden everybody's gotta eat maggots to
servant grasshoppers.
It fucking Marriner games or whatever the hell they doing up there.
Um,
this is America.
We don't eat grasshoppers.
Well,
you Doritos,
Taco Bell.
Yeah.
You give them the sun.
Everybody.
I'm telling you that would turn this country around.
Turn this country Rao.
Just give him a son.
That's it.
So anyways,
I flew the other day on a,
on Tuesday,
I hadn't flown like a month and I flew like a fucking champ to the point.
I actually got a God damn compliment from my instructor.
A unsolicited said,
you're flying great today.
Made me feel really good.
Okay,
I've done my auto rotations.
I'm ready to get back out there and solo.
So there's a flight I want to do.
I want to fly up to San fucking Barbara Solo.
So that's what I'm working towards and um,
I'm really looking forward to it and been flying a lot in the valley and
everything,
getting to know all of that stuff.
Um,
it's so fucking cool.
Yesterday we were actually going to two days ago,
we're going to try to fly over to Santa Monica airport cause I know that they're
going to,
they are allegedly closing it in five years.
We'll see what the fuck happens.
So I was like,
well I never landed there.
I might as well go over there and check that place out.
But what we wanted to do,
like pad work,
they don't like to do that over there.
Noise abatement's and all that.
They don't want some helicopter flying around and all that shit.
So we just said fuck it.
We flew up along the coast from it by the Pacific Palisades.
And you just sit in there and look,
and that's what this the whole give him the son Shit came from,
I looked,
I said,
look at that fucking house they're building.
This house was the size of this house.
I looked at it and I said to the instructor,
go,
that looks like if they're building a fucking mall that I would never go into
going like that's going to be too crowded.
And it was somebody's house.
It was going to cost half a fucking billion dollars and there was some prince of
some fucking country in the Middle East,
you know,
was going to move.
That's like his fucking house on the other side of the world.
That's his cottage.
And that right there,
I was just like,
how much fucking money we give it to these people.
It's time to give the old companies to son.
That's,
that's all you do.
So there's still in control of everything.
You know,
they could give us empty threats,
well shot off,
you know,
like they could do it.
Um,
so anyways,
we're flying over there and I'm just looking at all these fucking houses and I
looked down,
I see this one,
it was fucking beautiful house.
I got Jesus Christ.
Look at that one.
They have like these,
this glass where you couldn't see it at all.
Like ceiling.
The floors is fucking look like a goddamn yet.
But it was a house and uh,
and all those guys,
they was give tours so they know all the celebrities.
He's like,
oh,
that's so and so's fucking house.
And I was like,
wow,
that's what 20 million a movie gives you.
And I'm not going to say the guy's name because he probably has enough fucking
people looking at his house.
Although recently they said that he sold it.
So I have no fucking idea.
But anyways.
MMM.
I had a great time.
I did have a great time.
The only thing it was whenever I land off airport,
I all,
all the fucking shit that I know to do the downwind checks,
you know,
all of that.
I forget to do all of it.
That's the only part I fucked up.
So we're doing like this pinnacle landing and I,
you know,
you set up downwind base and then go final and I fucking,
I was coming in for landing,
I was still doing like 65 knots.
Like I'm supposed to be down to like 30,
you know,
slowing down and shit.
Guys going right,
you're going a little fast.
I want to do some s turns here.
But anyways,
I am a,
yeah,
very excited to do that type of shit.
And a,
this is the time when I would usually read some advertising there,
but I don't have any,
what else can I talk about here?
Let's look it up.
I have to hum my password.
I say can't,
you know,
I got in here late and I watched the little at the end of the fucking Yankee
scheme,
the BB bombers over there fucking kicking the shit out of everybody.
Um,
oh,
you know,
I love about my building here in New York is we have rooftop access and to,
I feel like that's part of,
uh,
the New York spirit.
She gotta be up on a fucking roof.
The only thing that sucks is you can't smoke up there.
You know?
They just have like chairs.
I don't even think he can smoke.
I just said smoke.
I don't think you can eat.
You know what I mean?
I think you just can go up there and like read books.
It's like,
what the fuck?
You know what I mean?
It's probably camera's up a cane and go up there and bang your bride.
He like this going like,
Huh.
Coiling and he can't do that anymore.
Back in the day,
back in the 90s when I was there,
I got pine sharp on in the background.
Somebody is trying to sell a Maria eliminator.
Yeah,
it looks like that looks like an Apollo three speed I think.
I don't know if you guys noticed,
but bill on F is for family has a bike like that and it was a bike I always
wanted and my parents were like,
no,
we're going to get you the nerdy more fucking,
we're not going to get you one of those cool chopper looking bikes.
We're going to get you one of the fucking nerdy.
Once you know beach rambler,
let's see what the fuck this guy's asks him for.
This the f three eliminator
eliminate or mark to or what are you going to do?
How much are you going to get through this?
So what are your concerns court?
Um,
original
as well.
They always fuck him over actually the seat,
uh,
some of the metal fleck as you can see,
has a little scratch on it.
So I'm going to give you one 90th of what your asking price was.
MMM.
You don't kills me.
Those fucking bikes were like,
I don't know what they do.
Probably 60,
70 bucks,
which is a lot of money back in the day and now they're worth like hundreds and
hundreds of pills called inflation.
It's called the Federal Reserve.
Um,
all right.
I just went down the rabbit hole.
All right.
Um,
that is the thing.
I was just checking in and you guys,
I've just given you a couple of laps on your ride home or whatever the fuck it
is that you're doing.
Um,
I guess I'll do the advertising read whenever the fuck I get that and I'll just
splice it on the end of this,
which is what you're going to listen to in two seconds.
So I don't know why I just explained it.
All right.
Uh,
by the way,
um,
balcony seats for Paul Versey standup special on August 13th at the Tarrytown
Music Hall have now gone on sale.
A tickets are going fast for the two shows to very excited about me and Pete
Davidson are going to go out,
go out before Paul's show to a warm up the crowd that night.
Do a little fucking smothers brothers thing.
I think we're just going to try out new material.
I'm going to run that by him.
We just,
you know,
he'll try a new joke,
then I'll try a new joke and then you guys get to judge it.
Who's you?
Like better.
All right.
And then have a fucking wins.
Gets a Goddamn Pie.
I don't know what,
we'll figure something out.
It's going to be a great night.
So thank you everybody for watching after for family.
And thank you for helping out the all things comedy network.
We're producing our first standup special with the Great Paul Versey,
who soon to become a household name.
So to start selling out nationwide,
developing a drug habit,
leaving his family,
taking his family back.
He says,
did taking the fucking Hollywood ride,
not pause and I'll go do that.
Yeah.
I can't wait to see Paul Versey with money.
I cannot fucking wait.
Okay.
First of all,
his bedroom's going to look like a footlocker.
He's going to have all these fucking Jordans up on the wall.
He's going to have like 19 different,
he's going to have a gold chain for every fucking day of the month
kind of car would.
He likes a four door,
sit down,
some giant gangster fucking look at car,
you know.
Okay.
Fucking walking humor door.
I can't wait to see it.
I really can't wait to see it.
It's going to be,
there's certain people,
you know,
they get money.
They're fucking boring.
Um,
I've been guilty of that.
But,
uh,
there's other people you're like,
Oh God,
I can't wait to see this.
This is going to be some fucking legendary shit if he,
like if I came into Paul's House and he's somehow in a split entry house,
figured out how to put a war,
the world is mine fountain at the foot of the landing of the fucking two stairs.
One goes up,
one goes down.
I wouldn't surprise me in the least and I can't wait to see it cause I love the
guy.
All right,
that's it.
Here comes from advertising that I'm going to read some point in the future,
but you're going to hear it now.
Uh,
have a great weekend.
You fucking cans over there and uh,
thank you to everybody.
Bought two tickets out here in port Chester.
I'll see you tonight.
Tomorrow.
Say,
all right,
here's the reeds,
the Jackie,
she's black cops.
Everyone.
There's only so many opportunities.
I liked to wear a Tuxedo.
Yeah.
When you're under a mom giving people this shot,
uh,
it can give you the sense.
So when your big day or special event rolls around this spring,
look just as great as you feel.
There's fruit,
they feel better when they were like black tops@laptops.com
yeah,
with high quality rental suits and Tuxedos delivered to your doorstep.
The black talks gives you a new way to rank what would are free home try on.
You get to see the fit and feel the quality.
Assume that your balls roll around the past months before the event before you a
man.
And the best part is it's completely done online.
The Black Tufts Dotcom lets you create your luck or choose from tons of styles.
So that was six elected outfits.
I love you to do this on the Internet someday when you're fucking robot with
placement shows up dressed like James Bond,
like I recognize that.
I recognize that face that it fucking kills you.
It won't be a gentleman robot.
So it's like this usually retail for 1200 bucks today,
but as the black socks,
they started just $95 why would you say 1200 bucks?
Yeah.
They just start at nine five not the $1,200 one
oh Jesus.
If you have any questions or issues,
their
expert customer,
you can see there's your back every step of the way.
After ordering your suit will arrive 14 days before your bet.
If anything is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a free replacement right away.
When your event is over,
just drop your rental back in the mail.
Shipping is free both ways.
How easy is that stand out at your event for the right reasons with laptops to
get $20 off your purchase it the black Tux dotcom slash for the Black Tux.
Dotcom slash burn for $20 off of your purchase.
All right,
lift.
Everybody lifts knows that their drivers are what?
Keep them moving so they do everything they can to make sure that the drivers
are in happy on every trip.
Man.
Lyft is the ride sharing company that believes in treating his people better
live.
This is so much shade against Uber.
It's hilarious.
We actually treat our people like people.
Let's believes that being a ride sharing drivers should be fun.
And you're having a good time if you're out of good science or your passengers.
Well,
I mean within reason,
a lift was can think of some scenarios while I was with was the first to offer
in activity.
When you drive for Lyft,
you keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers have been pay over $200 million in tips.
Since the feature was introduced.
Express pay less drivers get paid almost instantly instead of waiting for weeks.
Lyft as even taking the guesswork out of pickups,
the new amp device use color coding to help passengers find their drivers.
You can earn hundreds.
That's actually really cool.
I was wondering why they will lit up differently.
Uh,
you can earn hundreds of dollars a week plus tips on earn more money,
dry forwards.
Never been easier to give yourself a raise.
It's a simple formula.
Appy drivers being happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out of 10 Lyft rides in a perfect five star rating.
Go to lift.com/bird today and you can get a $500 new driver bonus.
That's live,
l y f t.com/ [inaudible] dot com slash pro limited time only terms apply.
Okay.
All right.
That ends the ads for this week.
Please enjoy the music and a half hour of a special Thursday afternoon podcast
from a Thursday afternoon.
That went by or maybe never happened,
so,
okay.
What's
going on?
It's bill burr and this is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
June 29th,
2009 and that was an MP three by one of my listeners.
Uh,
kind of an old school one,
which I kind of liked.
Uh,
you know,
little old school,
a little new school,
you know,
still had,
they had the eighties heavy metal radio station sound to it.
And then it also had like that,
the newer sort of a,
what do they call that?
That cookie monster singing where people
red,
red row.
You know,
I really respect the musicianship of being able to play that fast,
but I have to admit,
I,
maybe I'm too old,
but I just can't listen to some
guy go,
Rah,
Rah Rah Rah
without laughing.
Or it just seems ridiculous to me.
But,
uh,
but maybe that's me.
I Dunno.
But,
uh,
thank you for the a,
I know those things take a long time to put together,
so I appreciate anybody who does one.
And I actually got a,
I got another one this week was,
so,
uh,
next week there'll be a different intro and if you're new to my podcast,
that's one of the things,
um,
every once in a while one of my listeners will put together an MP three and then
it takes me eight days to figure out how to fucking sink it up and garage band.
I just wish I knew a way where I could play it and talk over it like you would
on like a,
a,
a fucking a I guess a radio show if anybody knows how to do that.
You know what?
There was a fucking question I was going to ask you guys some sort of computer
question.
God dammit.
I gotta I gotta write these things down.
I really got to write these things down anyways.
I'm still in New York City,
everybody.
I am down to my,
uh,
the final week.
I just have one more scene to shoot.
I got two lines.
That's all I got left and then,
uh,
then I'm out of the movie and it's been,
it's been great.
It's been a great experience.
And,
uh,
but I am going a little bit nuts because I've been away from my life for so
long,
which,
uh,
I dunno.
I think a lot of you guys maybe don't get to experience that if you have more of
a real life where you get to just go to work and then come home.
Um,
you don't like when you go on vacation,
how it's fun for the first fucking week,
you know,
and everything's cool.
We're going to be,
it takes a couple of days to relax,
but then they comes to that point where you get an a vacation where you kind of
ready to go home and you know,
you need to,
you just need to sleep in your own bed.
Yeah,
I just want to go home,
you know,
see my dog and fucking,
put them in a full pull,
put,
you know,
put her in a full Nelson,
maybe give her a couple of jabs to her,
a little doggie nose.
Uh,
yeah,
that's another thing.
If you new to my podcast,
I really love kicking the shit out of my dog.
Um,
it's uh,
I'm kidding.
You know,
now you know what this really is.
This is me,
my inability to say that I miss people in my life.
Okay.
This is my fucking Irish Boston,
you know,
inability to hug right now to say that I actually,
uh,
you know,
maybe miss people in my life.
See,
I have to have an ambiguous right now.
So anyways,
yeah.
So I've been fucking staying here in New York,
you know,
going to the same God damn diner every morning.
And uh,
I know this is a really hacky premise and I say that every week as I throw out
hacky shit,
but what is the deal with ordering orange,
orange juice and they charge,
they charge.
I had a small,
they charged me for 50,
you know,
I got a couple of eggs so I thought it was going to come in and about like
fucking uh,
you know,
the $13 range and next thing you know it's like I owed like 25 bucks is cause I
ordered a fucking orange juice.
Is it,
cause everybody loves it.
You know,
there's no shortage of oranges.
It's,
I dunno,
Jesus Christ,
this podcast socks,
this rate,
this podcast really sucks.
Thank God I had an intro cause I I d I literally just ran out of steam right
there.
You know what is the deal with oranges bill?
Huh?
All right,
let's talk about some fucking topical Shit.
Jeezy you would think that I would bring up some other shit.
Maybe some other,
let's just backtrack with all the crazy shit that's happened this week.
All right.
Bernie Madoff just got a 150 fucking years in jail
for being the piece of shit that he evidently is because the guy got convicted
for a,
you know,
that whole Ponzi scheme.
I think that's great.
I totally backed that.
The fact that they gave him the maximum amount.
I was already getting pissed when his lawyer was like,
well,
he's this age now and so he's probably only going to live another 13 years.
So we want,
we'd like if he just gave him 12 years,
well why should he get out at all?
He's going to live another 13 years.
Well let's give him 14 to make sure he fucking dies in prison.
You know,
I'll tell you,
out of all the fucking things that you can do short of like physically
assaulting somebody is,
you know,
if you steal old people's money,
okay.
And they work their asses off their whole life.
You know,
especially some of these rich old people who,
you know,
worked really hard taking advantage of sweatshop labor and you come in there
and no,
I'm just fucking around,
but seriously,
you know what I mean?
Like,
and then they ended up having to eat dog food.
You took their whole life's work away,
man.
I can't imagine that.
I mean,
God bless those old people for not coming down there and just literally killing
the guy.
I would actually contemplate that.
You know,
what kind of jail do you think that they would send to you?
Send you two if you would like an 85 year old guy who had worked his whole life,
you get 85 that means you probably fought in at least one war.
So you're a veteran.
She already got the like right there.
Everybody's like,
well fuck that.
That guy used to be a marine,
you know,
fought for our freedom.
He did the right thing his whole life.
Then he got burned by this fucking feathered mullet jackass and then he shot him
in the head.
He actually saved us some fucking,
some tax payer money.
I don't know what kind of jail where they send you to.
They couldn't send you to 11 worthless.
It's not like you're fucking fought dogs like Michael Vick.
Right?
So anyways,
that guy got 150 years.
I think that's that.
That's great.
But I don't understand why those other bankers who loaned all of our hard earned
money out to fucking homeless people,
you know,
who then defaulted on loans and then not only do they not go to jail,
they asked for more fucking money that they already print and the print and then
they charged us the interest on it.
Is Anybody,
did anybody out there major in economics?
Can anybody out there explained to me how how we keep printing money with no
gold behind it and catch up isn't like $72 a bottle.
Can anybody out there?
Can anybody explain that to me?
You know,
and if you listen to this podcast,
you know that's a major pet peeve of mine was when somebody comes up to me and
they tell me that whatever I'm talking about,
they majored in it in college as if that's some sort of fucking uh,
uh,
what is the expression thorn in your crown?
That's not it.
Jewel in your side.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
dude,
you,
I hate people who go to college and Major and shit.
And then they think that that automatically,
that makes them a fucking expert on the subject.
It's like douchebag.
You went there and you read the books that they gave you.
Okay?
The fucking school is aligned with a certain like viewpoint.
And then you read 50 fucking books with the same goddamn viewpoint,
all right there fucking viewpoint,
which is encouraging you to,
to,
to go out and pay for a fucking education that's not even worth what they're
charging you.
For you to come out of school,
be 80 a hundred grand in debt.
Somewhere along the line,
the banks give you a fucking credit card with like a $3,000 limit only,
even though you're only making 300 bucks a week at hot topic or whatever the
fuck you're doing.
So they get,
you're buried in that debt and then you're supposed to knock up some broad by 26
28 have a kid and then go buy a fucking house.
She had done,
you're on the wheel to yet 90 you'll fucking done.
All right.
So I don't know what I'm talking about,
but I'm just,
you know what,
I'm sick of.
I just don't like when I make a point and somebody challenges it.
That's what it is.
Especially with the college education.
But anyways,
I don't understand why those guys aren't in fucking jail.
So anyways,
let's,
let's back up more.
Michael Jackson.
I had no idea how big that guy was.
I forgot.
I don't know if any of the rest of you will like this,
but I literally,
I forgot how famous that guy was.
Why I should say more like how talented he was.
Because the last,
really,
to be honest with you,
from about 91 92,
the last 1718 years was so not even about his music or his talent.
It was all about his plastic surgery.
Those trials he went through,
um,
the plastic surgery,
you know,
just all the weird stuff.
And then another thing about him was I really felt that he was kind of like a
comedian who stopped writing a brilliant comedian.
You know,
he just kept wearing those penny loafers and he kept doing that,
kicking his leg up.
You know,
he does that little knee thing and then the little mime step to the side and he
throws his fucking hand up into the air,
sort of the John Travolta like,
I'm going to disco dance,
but wait a second,
I'm stopping,
you know.
But anyway,
so the guy dies and then uh,
they started showing all his videos on MTV,
if you can fucking believe it.
They actually showed videos on MTV and I came in from shooting the movie had
like five in the morning and I sat there and I watched his videos for like a
fucking hour and I,
I remembered once again,
how would a giant,
that guy was,
I don't know if you guys are old like me,
but for some of you youngsters out there when that thriller video came out,
I can't even explain.
It was,
it was fucking great.
It was ridiculous.
I just wished that you could just watch all the videos that,
that like
had taken place before that video.
Have you ever seen that journey?
One,
that awful journey video where,
I mean I'm not really into the music of journey,
but those were all top notch fucking musicians.
All right.
What's his face there?
Uh,
the lead singer,
they're unbelievable voice even though I just didn't like,
and uh,
they had drama.
Steve Smith is like,
he's continued to have,
he's like one of the greatest drummers in the world right now.
Considered that.
But for some reason when they made the video,
you have all these top notch fucking musicians.
For some reason they decided that they should rather than have one of the
greatest drummers in the world drum they,
that he should air drum and that all the guitars should air guitar.
And then the worst thing ever,
they had the keyboardist air keyboard
and then they will all fucking just hunched in together,
like sort of just stopping the foot.
It was fucking embarrassing then.
So anyways,
so thriller came out and basically what MTV would do was they actually had a
debut with the video.
That's how fucking huge it was.
I remember they used to do debuts,
but it was just everybody fucking watched it.
And it wasn't just like they debuted it and then it was in the rotation they
like showed it at like whatever,
like three o'clock in the afternoon,
right is the kids came home from school and then they will like we will be
showing it again at six and then you'd go live your little fucking,
you know,
I'm 12 year old life and then you'd come back with fucking five 58 you'd sit
there with your jaw on the floor,
you'd it again.
And then they'd be like,
we're going to show it again at nine.
And then once we get off right before you went to,
you've watched it again.
And then the next day everybody go to school.
Do they show it four times?
I saw it five times,
no where you'd have to stay up to three to fucking board like these stupid
arguments.
And they did that full,
I don't feel like a fucking week.
It was unreal.
And I actually watched it.
Uh,
that's the first time I,
they actually showed the full length one and I don't think I've seen the full
length version of that since the 80s.
And uh,
I dunno,
it was fucking amazing.
And then it's also sad because you're looking at the guy and that's what I was
doing.
I looked at the old videos,
I'm like,
he was a good looking guy.
The fuck did he do or like a,
as you're watching them gradually,
you know,
have operations you just right there.
We should have stopped right there.
Yeah,
right,
right there.
Okay.
Stop.
Freeze one,
two,
three red light.
But he just kept fucking going.
And uh,
I dunno,
one of the thing that pissed me off was I was reading in the post,
it was a guy writing for the post saying how he actually was at the second child
molestation trial and was saying how ridiculous it was and how he couldn't even
believe it went to trial.
That the charges were such bullshit.
And I just remember thinking going,
where the fuck was that story in the post during that time?
Because I was reading the post because I like the sports page and all they did
was just talk about what,
uh,
you know,
they,
they had him convicted in the paper.
So in my mind,
he was fucking convicted.
I,
I hate when papers do that.
Okay.
Like they go all the way to the left and then when they realize you know that
they can't go to the left anymore,
then they present the fucking right.
You know,
I dunno what the fuck I'm saying that,
but all I know is I actually started believing that he was just a really
gullible jackass and was kind of wide open to that stuff.
But,
you know,
then this is how this how I'm going to leave it because the guy was acquitted
twice.
I'm going to,
I'm going to
believed that he was innocent,
but this is the deal.
I would believe that the guy was innocent,
but if I had a kid,
I wouldn't leave them alone with them for like three seconds.
How about that?
You know what I mean?
That's
not Mike.
I hear you.
I totally believe you.
Yeah.
Those charges were fucked up.
Uh,
we're going to go now and,
uh,
yeah,
we're going to slowly back towards the car.
And,
uh,
as I listened for the Choo Choo train,
as it goes around your house to make sure that I don't get run over by it.
Uh,
no,
I don't want a glass of wine.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
A Farrah Fawcett died.
This is a really sad,
weak Farrah Fawcett.
I believe that was my first,
um,
no,
it wasn't.
You know what?
Kate Jackson was my first fantasy famous girlfriend,
and that's when she was on the rookies.
You guys remember the rookies?
Ben and then Ben and Ben Nnnn.
It did.
It did it did it.
Remember that Shit.
Well,
there,
those great seventies
fucking TV shows in all right.
Theme songs like that anymore,
right?
Number Swat.
But uh,
but that Baba Dilla,
Dilla,
back when they had musicians,
it'd be a whole fucking orchestra.
Pbs To make God damn livings writing TV themes.
But anyways,
Kate Jackson,
she was like the original Dimi more,
however you say that fucking cougars name.
Huh?
With their fucking lead pipe titties.
Um,
okay.
Yeah,
she played,
she was,
it was the whole shear,
the sexy voice.
Absolutely beautiful eyes,
beautiful hair,
the whole fucking thing.
She was so fucking hot and she was dressed like a nurse and there was no fucking
Internet.
There was no porn.
There was no,
I had nothing.
That was a man without a fucking country back then.
So I would just sit there fucking Mesmer.
It was a,
it was a perfect show.
And she's married to the cop.
The cops character's name I still remember was Mike Danco.
Right.
That's like a classic seventies macho.
I'm fucking hitting it right name Mike Danco.
Uh,
Mike Danco mother fucker.
That's how we should have said it.
There's no,
they should have beeped out motherfucker every week when somebody said his name,
you know,
and I used to watch that show gone.
I can call and that's what I'm going to do in life.
I'm going to be a cop.
I'm changing my name to Mike Danko and I'm marrying some hot ass fucking nurse
and I'm banging are in that fucking nurse outfit.
I don't even think shit like that.
I was like so innocent.
I'd even have thoughts like that.
I,
I was literally like in love.
Remember that when you actually had that in before you ever met some girl who
just fucked up your whole view of women and you actually viewed them as if they
were like these angels because they were so gorgeous.
You know,
before you realize that a three out of four weeks a month,
they're going to be absolute fucking maniacs.
But I digress.
So,
um,
yeah,
so Farrah Fawcett dies.
Talk about,
you know,
out of all the fucking days to die,
you die on a day when a guy do.
Michael Jackson is so famous.
If you guys seen that thing,
an entire prison yard in the Philippines work nine hours to reenact the thriller
dance,
and they did it and they put it up on Youtube.
These are prisoners in the fucking Philippines.
Okay.
That the risk of pissing off all you white trash,
ice road truckers out there.
Fuck Elvis Presley.
Elvis Presley
was,
he just wasn't anywhere near that.
He was,
he was huge jobs.
A bunch of people right now.
Now wait a minute,
that's the fucking King,
man.
You don't say that Shit.
Elvis Presley was the king.
You understand that buddy Michael Jackson was the king of Pop.
Do you understand that?
That means he is.
His Kingdom is clarified.
He's the king of everything.
No,
he's the king of fucking pop.
Elvis Presley was the fucking king period,
which means Michael Jackson was his fucking subject.
Um,
I get that.
And also Elvis Presley didn't have the advantage of the worldwide web.
You know what I mean?
Where you can have as little talent as the chocolate rain guy and you can go
national.
So I can only imagine if,
you know,
Ed Sullivan could have put that fucking,
I don't know what the hell I'm talking about.
Whatever.
I had to defend Elvis a little bit.
I,
you know,
I used to make fun of Elvis and then I went to his house one time when I was on
the road and I went in there thinking I was going to get a bit and thinking it
was going to be funny.
And you know what,
it was just sad.
I just saw a guy who was basically the original behind the music guy.
Um,
and who was like,
even in death,
we're all Wah.
I just,
I felt like I was just like,
I'm just intruding on this guy's house.
And then you walk out back in the his grave and everybody's taking pictures next
to his grave.
It's just like,
uh,
you know that how should be haunted.
Like Elvis should literally be haunting that house and scaring the shit out of
those fucking people.
But God knows they still wouldn't even get it.
They would still thinking,
you know,
he's singing,
he's singing from the grave.
It's a little more vulgar than I remember,
you know.
I mean,
I guess he didn't ride his own lyrics.
Hell,
we probably fucking stole.
If you believe what some of them people of color are saying about his music.
Um,
all right,
what are we doing here?
Let's get on with the,
Oh,
wait a minute and now we have to go back before that.
Who Else fucking die?
That was some Ed Mcmahon died.
Ed Mcmahon.
Ed make man died.
And I hated after fucking,
you know,
Michael,
Ed Mcmahon dies,
then a Farrah Fawcett dies and Michael Jackson dies.
And then there's always that Douche bag who has to be like,
yeah,
she bed.
Things come in threes.
You know,
bad things come in threes.
Really?
What about Dave?
David Carradine.
You know what about him?
He died.
That makes for stupid.
Some old lady died of heat stroke.
I saw that on the news.
That's five.
What was it all in the same week?
Well,
you know what?
I got two words for you.
Billy Mays,
not Billy Mays and I fucking die toe.
So there you go.
That's four famous mother fuckers in one God damn week.
You know what?
Somebody told me something,
somebody wrote me a hilarious fucking email was saying like,
how the fuck they couldn't believe that they didn't see Billy Mays dying.
They couldn't see his death come when he clearly looks like he ate four pounds
of Bacon every God damn morning.
He really did.
You ever do?
I hate when people do that.
Like you always predict some shit after it happens.
But I gotta admit once Billy Mays died,
you were kind of like,
well,
he really did have that heart attack face,
didn't he?
He just had that,
that bluedot beard and he was always screaming.
And not only that,
he was around all that cleaner.
How many takes do you think they did as he was sitting there spraying that oxy
wash?
Fucking whenever the hell it was called,
that oxy oxy clean.
Do you guys ever get that shit?
Did you,
did you feel that it made your whites a whole lot wider?
I don't think it did.
That's why I think Billy Mays.
Dot.
I think it was from all that lying,
he just couldn't do it anymore.
Screaming about fucking alarm clocks that can scratch your back or whatever the
hell he had.
I Dunno.
So whenever,
there you go.
What a fucking month.
Huh?
David Carradine.
God bless them.
And I really think it's bad that people actually give them shit.
I have no problem with,
with the fact that he liked to put on fish nets and hang himself.
You know,
I hope that I'm that much of a freak.
It's 72 fucking years old.
You know,
I just,
I got really like a,
I got inspired by the fact that he was doing that,
that at that age,
you know what I mean?
Do you just picture your 72 you know,
you just fucking hobbling around.
I'll tell you that paper boy,
he played playing with a paper too far away from the door.
That's what,
that's what I pictured 72 as you know,
you all excited.
You got that.
You can't go up the stairs anymore.
You've got to sit in that electronic fucking thing that brings you all the way
up the stairs.
You know?
Remember that Shit I was talking about a long time ago where you have that you
have the elevated toilet seat because anybody can use gravity and get their
fucking old ass down on a toilet seat.
But it still takes the quad strength to get the fuck back up off of it.
But you can't afford somebody to help you up off the toilet seat.
So you have to have an elevated toilet seat.
So you basically for the rest of your fucking life,
you take a fucking shit
standing there like a third basement,
you know at the ready position.
That's how you take a shit,
you know,
hands on your knees standing there like fucking Brooks Robinson waiting to
squeeze one out.
Little metamucil wouldn't hurt either.
And then you got David Carradine.
See I'm telling you guys that that's why each stretching is so fucking
unbelievable if you want it.
That's the biggest thing you can do other than eating well I think to try and
still feel young because if you don't stretch your hamstrings and everything
off,
if you don't stretch it out,
I guess atrophied.
I don't even know what the fuck that means.
All I know is I noticed,
you know,
I haven't been that good about it and I've been running with my dog and I was
like,
Holy Shit.
I am rapidly approaching the age where I can't run anymore.
You know?
I mean that happens anyways.
At some point you're not going to be able to run,
but if you stop stretching that is the quickest.
I think that is the quickest way.
And I'm saying that having absolutely no degree in nutrition,
physical therapy or anything whatsoever,
so you can take that to the fucking bank.
All right,
let's get into the podcast stuff here that you guys send it.
Um,
here's one for you.
Last week I was talking about grenades.
I don't know why,
I can't remember why,
but I had somehow as I presented the question,
uh,
what would happen if I,
you know,
oh,
I remember because we were talking about that,
that guy sent in that email about that psycho who lived across the street,
who was in the army and he used to sneak shit home and try and sell it.
And the guy was in a bar trying to sell a fucking grenade.
And uh,
be honest.
You'd buy it.
Wouldn't you give three Budweisers in?
You're going through a breakup or maybe you just young and you have hope and he
just got that one fucking,
that,
that industrial area that they're just developing in your town and you're like,
all right,
this is the deal.
We'll pull the pin,
we'll throw it,
and then we'll fucking rob you.
Of course you're going to do that.
So anyway,
so I presented like,
I was wondering like what,
what the level of explosion,
the concussive force,
whatever the fuck it is of a grenade.
Like could,
if I,
if I had threw a grenade on the other side of my bed and I dove on the other
side of my bed,
blocked up my ears and it exploded.
Okay.
And I'm talking about one of those beds,
those beds where you know,
you can't steal it because they got like the fucking,
the wood frame underneath it.
Um,
would I be able to survive?
So from somebody from,
uh,
the,
the Marines told me,
he said,
Bill,
a hand grenade in your hotel room would definitely fuck your day up with a 15
mil,
15 meter kill radius inside of an enclosed space.
Your head and asshole would be indistinguishable,
indistinguishable from one another.
I hope that answers your question.
Yeah,
I would say you were pretty specific there.
So anyways,
for you who suck at math,
uh,
a meter is a little more than a yard.
And I only remember that from that commercial back in the 70s when they were
trying to teach us the metric system,
which bombed miserably.
So 15 times three would be 45 feet and that is a radius of 45 feet.
Jesus Christ.
So then I,
I wrote the guy back cause I really found that interesting.
And I guess because it's enclosed that the ceiling kind of keeps the blast in
and the walls and all that.
I guess if you're outside you have a better chance.
I don't know,
I'd have to talk more about this,
but this immediately has opened up a new podcast thing for anyone who's in the
military.
I want to learn about these fucking weapons and a what they can do to you.
And I'm going to tell you right now,
anybody with a fucking gun,
there's nothing they like better than telling you what the fucking gun would do
to you.
Have you ever noticed that
anytime somebody gets a gun,
what do they say?
I,
you know,
I just got it to go hunting.
Right?
And then you'd be like,
well what's,
you know,
what,
what's,
what's that gun like in the guys do from here?
If I shot you right from here and I shot you,
a whole fucking shoulder would come off,
you spinal cord would be dangling.
They always do that shit.
So,
you know,
what's the point I have in a weapon if you don't know what it would do to a
human being.
That's what I say.
Huh.
Anybody else?
And to be held.
So Braveheart fan.
Um,
all right.
You know,
I actually sat down,
you know,
the day watching the whole history of the machine gun.
It was really fascinating.
Like this guy actually developed a machine gun cause he thought it was going to
save lives when he was in the civil war.
He was a,
Gatlin was a guy like the Gatlin gun.
He was sitting there talking about how he just saw the unbelievable level of
carnage in the civil war.
And you've gotta remember that's Americans shooting Americans.
So even if you're winning,
you know,
it's,
it's just a brutal thing.
And he was saying that if you've got a machine gun,
if he could do the work of 15 fucking people or 20 people,
um,
then that would be 19 less people who'd be out in the battlefield,
who could possibly lose their lives.
Of course he didn't do the math of,
well,
if they get one too,
then you need to have another guy with a machine gun and then it just keeps
fucking escalating.
But I did find it interesting,
or maybe that was just the bullshit that he said because he felt bad that he was
making money off of creating a weapon that could just literally mow down people.
Um,
anyways,
so here's the second part of the,
uh,
the grenade thing.
Um,
I think I,
what I,
what did I ask him?
Oh,
I remember that.
And so I emailed that guy back and I said,
okay,
so what if I had a suite,
a hotel suite,
and I throw it out into the living room area.
I closed the door in the bedroom and I dove behind the bed.
So then he proceeded to take a lot of time out of his day,
which I appreciate.
Here.
Wrote me a nice long email.
So this ladies and gentlemen is the answer to what if you had the suite and you
lit up,
you fucking pulled the pin on a grenade,
closed your bedroom door and dove behind the bed.
See,
I asked the questions that America wants to know.
All right,
here we go.
This guy said,
I did five years in the marines.
Uh,
he said,
I got on the Post Nine 11 redneck bandwagon.
Uh,
but by the time I got to Iraq in 2006,
we stopped using hand grenades indoors.
Normally,
normally we would just lob a few of those fuckers in a room and not have to
worry about the assholes on the other side.
Uh,
he goes,
I know that's cold blooded,
but hey,
he can have his 73 versions of an unspecified gender.
You know what?
That's a funny ass fucking loophole.
They really just say he gets 73 versions.
They don't say that they are women.
Do the that's fuck,
that's a great analogy.
Anyways.
Um,
he said,
and we replaced them with a flash grenades.
Uh,
basically we didn't want to kill innocent people in wind up on the cover of Time
magazine as the winner of Asshole of the year.
Um,
then we,
after we throw in the flash flash,
I just literally lost my place there,
the flash grenades.
Then we would charge into the room shooting.
Like I was a in the Goddamn Matrix.
Um,
but anyways,
I have seen hand grenades go off and there were two wait,
there were two ways of standard fragmentation.
Grenade can kill you.
One,
the blast itself,
which generally projects in a 15 foot radius.
Is anybody out there?
Can anybody explain to me the,
the blast itself,
how that kills you if you're not getting hit by shrapnel?
Just the blast.
Is that basically like the most psychotic invisible front kick?
Is that what an explosion is in,
in that,
that the air,
the force of the blast just hit you so hard.
It's like getting hit by like an invisible truck.
Is that what it is?
Um,
to be honest with you,
I've always kind of thought about that,
but I never really sat down and tried to figure it out.
And that's basically what I was able to,
to come up with having not researched anyways.
But anyways,
the guy says,
ah,
the concussion from the blast turns your insides into Jello if you're within a
five meter bubble.
So is that what happens?
You know what I mean?
So literally it's like getting hit by this invisible fucking,
uh,
what,
what did Bruce Lee have?
The one inch punch?
It's like getting hit by a few times.
Fucking 200.
I don't know.
Why don't I read the rest of us and maybe we'll find out.
Ah,
the second way you can die a horrific deaths is,
uh,
from a frag grenade is the fragmentation from the shell of the grenade and the
fragmentation of all the other shit like wood and pieces of other people that
the blast turns into shrapnel.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
You know what I mean?
As much as you watch the beginning of saving private Ryan,
like he's still really can't ever capture how fucking horrific that must be.
Um,
the amount of damage of frag will do to you in the next room,
depends on the wall in your suite,
what it's made out of.
If the walls are made out of concrete with rebar and shit inside,
you'll more than likely just shit your pants.
That's amazing.
So if there isn't like rebar in there,
which I'm imagining is those little steal things,
it could still fucking kill you.
Um,
if the wall is thin and some of the fragmentation may or may go through the wall
and hit you,
but you'll be safe from the blast itself.
And probably we'll probably live all just be screaming on the floor like that
guy and platoon is Barnes crawls over in,
digs the shit out with a knife.
Good Lord.
God bless you guys man.
I really do not have a difficult life here.
All right,
more.
Most doors on hotel rooms are pretty solid,
so I think could take a direct hit and not damage anything on the other side.
Also,
it depends on the type of grenade.
American hand grenades are the largest and the deadliest USA USA.
That's right.
Fucking America baby.
Um,
the Russian grenades are a little bit smaller.
I liked this.
I liked the whole,
uh,
the whole Phallic thing going on here with less fragmentation,
but I still wouldn't want to be in the same fucking zip code when one goes off.
Um,
and then the second question I asked him was,
um,
hearing loss is a big thing for me because a,
I played drums without earplugs for awhile and I also went and saw ACD,
seen a bunch of other heavy metal bands in every other time I wear earplugs and
I have tinnitus in my right ear,
which is a,
you know,
sometimes it can be a buzzing sound or it can be just a ringing sound and it
never goes away and it's driven people to suicide.
If it's loud enough.
Mine fortunately isn't.
It's just like,
like right now I can barely hear it.
Like if I actually just stopped talking,
if I stopped like late at night,
I can hear it when there's nothing going on.
If there's no background noise,
I just saw to here like this really low,
just soda
D
in my ear.
And I know a lot of you just was like,
Holy Shit,
that must be crazy.
But you actually,
that's my phone by the way.
If you're wondering what the other sound is,
that's not the sound in my ear.
That's letting me know that I have some fucking new Texas.
Um,
but anyways,
yeah,
it was always wondering like how these guys are in war and the shooting these
fucking machine guns and all this type of stuff.
Like how do you not lose your hearing?
And he said to,
to answer your second question,
he said,
I have a condition called Tinnitus,
uh,
which I basically explained,
but I'll have them explain it to,
he said,
which is a permanent permanent ringing in my ears.
And my left ear is pretty fucked up as well.
Some dude opened up with a machine gun right next to my head and I didn't have
an ear plug in my left ear.
So I guess you guys wear earplugs over there.
But I would think sometimes if you get ambushed,
you don't have a minute and then he just got to fucking open up anyways.
I don't really notice the ringing unless it's really fucking quiet and since I
live in the middle of a dense urban area,
it's never really fucking quiet.
So it's not an issue.
In combat we wear earplugs that work pretty well.
Shooting aside small rooms is still pretty fucking loud though.
The loudest thing over there are aircraft and anything that explodes.
I'm talking about the loudest fucking thing you would ever hear in your life.
Also,
we normally communicate non verbally through hand signals and just knowing where
you should be in a certain situation.
Oh,
he's addressing the fact that you know you always watched those cop movies and
the and the sort of whisper after they shot a couple of rounds,
you know and I've shot a gun without fucking earplugs.
That's another dumb thing I did when my hearing and I couldn't hear anything.
So there's no fucking way I could then whisper to somebody next to me going,
you go around back and I'll try to keep him busy here cause they got to be going
like,
hey,
I can't fucking hear you.
Um,
so anyways,
he said they use hand.
Um,
anyways,
besides shouting within earshot of the enemy is retarded since they counter
attack and the element of surprise is lost.
Uh,
this email was probably longer than that ladies.
Oh,
that ladies who've made fun of your suit on Kona.
Not Dude,
I totally appreciate that man.
If there's anybody else out there that like,
really,
uh,
that's like some time life books kind of stopped,
you know,
when they talk about what it's really like.
So if anybody else,
if I have anybody who's a overseas,
God knows you get the Internet over there,
if you're over there in Iraq or if you're over there in Afghanistan and I'm
trying to think of a question or for any of the listeners,
have any questions of stuff over there.
Um,
I got one for you.
You know,
you sit there and you train and you go through bootcamp and you do all that
stuff,
you know,
and uh,
you get yourself ready for battle and then you go on over there.
You know,
I know my biggest fear would have been like,
what am I going to be?
That guy who freezes up and is crying in the fetal position spooning his weapon
in a foxhole is someone's screaming at me private bar for Christ's sake,
get your shit together.
You best on fuck yourself pile.
I mean what happens is it does it just naturally clicking.
Cause I would think even in my first battle,
even if I didn't pussy out,
I would still be a spazz
fucking empty and entire clip.
I remember talking to cops about this shit shit.
We had this cop on my radio show,
uninformed and by the way,
I have a new episode coming out.
We taped one a yesterday that will be out on July 3rd you can listen to that on
a XM two o two and a.
Anyways,
this comp was saying how a lot here,
he worked with guys the first time they pulled their weapons.
This is,
this is an old school guy,
so they still had like the six shooter and was saying they pulled a gun out of
the holster and by the time they brought it up level with the suspect,
they were literally out of bullets because they would be pulling it out and Bam,
like shooting literally into the ground in front of them.
They've had guys shoot themselves in the foot.
I'm just,
I just can't imagine the fucking adrenaline that is going through your,
your,
your body when something like that is happening.
So you know,
if it's not too painful,
obviously I'm not trying to have a big therapy session here.
This is supposed to be a comedy fuckers.
So if he got some funny stories or anything like that,
uh,
listen to me.
If you got any funny stories about war and engaging the enemy,
I dunno.
Anything that you would think would be fucking interesting.
Uh,
because I don't think I can,
I can answer any more questions about comedy.
I've pretty much answered them all.
But,
um,
I don't know,
I'm kind of speaking for the group here,
but I find that stuff really interesting because my only frame of restaurant
references when I watch movies and you see these guys,
you know,
they throw,
you never see that in a movie.
Like there's a grenade lands near the guys,
then somebody dives on top of it to save his buddies life.
Now from,
I always thought that you could do that,
but having just read that last one,
evidently if I did that,
then just,
you know,
all the 200,
whatever bones in my body would just turn into shrapnel.
And you know,
I don't know if people would die around me,
but they would definitely rolling around the ground trying to get my femur out
of the side of their fucking neck.
So we all learned something all right
on with the,
uh,
the podcast questions and you know,
it's just not,
the question is obviously posed to all veterans,
cops,
anybody rednecks.
If you got,
knows you probably threw a grenade at a duck and it's bill came back and hit you
in your foot.
Now you got to limp any,
any of those fucking stories.
I would,
I would love to hear all right.
Podcast questions of the week.
Uh,
this was a really interesting one.
Um,
this guy says,
Bill,
I come from a family where more than half of the women have gotten pregnant in
their teens and almost all of the men have ended up in jail,
in jail at various points in their lives.
Um,
so I've seen firsthand how having a kid when you're not ready and going to
prison at an early age can really fuck up your life.
And because I'm trying not to,
because I'm trying to end the tradition of poverty and dysfunction in my family,
I am very hesitant towards trying to hook up with random women and can be
considered a bit of a nerd also.
Um,
due to the fact that I don't have like two or three baby mothers and I'm never
bringing girls around the family,
you guessed it.
I've now been accused of being gay.
I guess by his,
his,
uh,
his family members.
Wow.
Okay.
I thought I came from a dysfunctional family.
Um,
all right.
I hope you see my dilemma here.
Uh,
if I go out of my way to prove I'm not gay,
that I'm acting,
acting like the classic Homophobe,
I'm not cool with that.
I'm also giving them power by trying to conform to their perception of what a
quote unquote real man is.
But if I ignore it,
they continued to talk shit.
It would be different if,
uh,
if,
if it were a collection of Douchebag,
jock saying things like this,
but it's not,
this is my fucking family.
The people who were supposed to love me unconditionally.
And yes,
as sad as it may seem,
my family members are that stupid and ignorant.
Uh,
they think being gay is something that warrants being made fun of.
Although I can,
uh,
I can really see the humor in this.
It really does hurt a little,
doing the right thing by staying in school and trying to make something out of
my life while staying out of trouble has gotten me where I'm accused of being
gay.
I'm so disgusted with my family that I'm seriously considering cutting each
member out of my family life.
Even my own mother,
parentheses,
my,
my father's dead.
Your thoughts.
Uh,
I think you're doing an amazing thing to be honest with you.
I think one of the hardest things to do is to grow up in a fucked up environment
and to be in the environment and be surrounded by totally immersed in it.
Yet still have the ability to pull yourself out of it and analyze it and look at
how other people are living and if they're living in a smarter way or a way that
appeals to you more,
to actually try to go and try to go in that direction without doing what most
normal people.
What most people do in that situation is they just look at other people.
If they're living a smarter life,
they just dismiss them as facts.
You know,
well,
I want to go to college.
Like these a bunch of things,
you know?
Um,
yeah,
that's a,
that's a lesson I learned late in life that you really have to watch out who
your,
uh,
who you surround yourself with because a,
you basically end up,
for the most part,
you end up doing what they do.
You just get sucked into that vortex.
So I don't know if that's the right word.
Whatever the fuck it is,
you get sucked into that their little,
uh,
their world.
And so if you're hanging out with people who are doing dumb shit fucking up
their lives,
the chances of you fucking up your life is going to be huge.
And Dude,
you don't want two or three babies with,
with two or three different women,
you know that everybody knows that.
And even those fucking retards who were doing it,
they know that.
And yet what it really is,
I really think this is a classic example of misery loves company.
And they,
when they're laying in bed at night,
they know that they fucked their lives up.
And you know what?
When people fuck their lives up.
You know what you do,
you lay in bed and you think about the first day,
that day when you fucked your life up and you wish you could just go back to it
and make a left instead of making a right.
That's what the fuck they're doing.
And the harsh reality is you can't go back in time and which leaves you with one
of two things.
You can even either man up and admit that you're the reason and you're
responsible for,
you know,
for the fact that your life is fucked up and you try to make the best of it and
try to actually help other people not make the same mistakes you have.
That's the most noble thing that you can do.
Or you can take the easy way out like most people and has tried to fucking do
that.
Misery loves company and drag everybody down with you.
That's all they're trying to do.
They're trying to drag you down to the bottom of the swimming pool so you can
drown in their fucking misery too.
So you're doing the right thing.
And if you have to a,
I don't know if you've got to like totally cut him out because it is your family
that is your mom and at some point,
you know,
they're not going to be around forever.
So it's never good to not go for long periods without communicating with your
family.
But you just kinda got to give yourself a halftime speech or a pregame speech
before you talked to him to make sure that,
uh,
you know,
you basically stay on point and uh,
yeah,
that,
those are my thoughts.
You're totally doing the right thing.
And I think,
uh,
I think he had a really strong person that you were able to see how fucked up
your family was.
That's a hard thing to do,
you know?
Um,
and try and correct it,
you know,
so it'll be great.
So then you'll,
you'll end up with the right woman,
you end up having great kids,
and then you'll,
you'll break the,
uh,
you'll break that circle.
But the problem that's dead you'll then run into is then when you have kids is
then they're going to want their fucked up kids to hang out with your,
uh,
enlightened kids.
And that'll be the hard thing because they are your cousins in and,
and whatever.
I Dunno,
it's a fucking mess.
But Dude,
you're on the right track.
So what do I think you should keep doing what you're doing and try to find some
middle ground where you keep them at an arm's length,
but you don't totally sever ties.
And when they,
and when they give you shit,
you know about being gay,
just give him shit right back.
Oh really?
Really?
I'm,
I'm gay.
What?
Because I don't have some fucking psycho coming in here trying to burn down my
fucking clothes cause I knocked up another fucking broad.
Not,
don't do that.
Don't go for it.
That's what I would do.
I'd go for the Juggler.
Like,
dude,
your life sucks.
Okay.
What's it like earning $400 a week and giving it in,
dividing up 380 of it and fucking given it to three different women and then
he'd go down to the fucking hot dog truck and buying you dinner.
You had dumped fuck,
you know,
put a shirt on and get your shit together.
I don't know.
I would just say mean shit.
Don't listen to me.
That for the first part of my advice was good.
But uh,
yeah.
Try to find a,
I dunno,
you know what,
talk to somebody else for the second half.
All right.
I'm not Deepak Chopra,
but I,
I got,
I think the first half of the advice I gave you was good.
All right.
So that's it.
You're doing the right thing.
There you go.
Something positive.
All right,
next question.
Hey Bill.
Um,
since you're pretty big sports fan,
I was wondering what we are opinion.
What was your opinion of soccer?
Um,
I'm not much of a fan.
I basically only watched some of the World Cup,
but today at the restaurant I was watching Brazil versus USA game.
And a few of my Brazilian coworkers,
um,
we're watching the game.
And for the first task,
for the first half,
I had a blast watching the game because basically it got to play out the
stereotypical over the top clueless American.
They would just dying inside when the u s scored a the first two goals and I got
to fuck with them.
I was yelling shit like a throw the flag.
Uh,
I'll tell you what Brazil needs to do.
They should call a timeout and regroup.
And then my coworkers were taking me serious,
furiously telling me that there are no timeouts and soccer.
Oh,
that's great dude.
They should call a fucking timeout.
I'll tell you,
there's nothing more fun than playing up the ignorant America.
You know,
that's the greatest thing you can do when you go to Europe and they start giving
you shit that you don't know anything about their and brace it.
Okay.
And just be like,
yeah,
dude,
I gotta be honest.
Nobody talks about your country and my country,
we have,
we know who the fuck you guys are.
What do,
I can't believe you're not all walking around a wooden shoes over here.
You guys have cars,
you know,
just fucking play it up.
All right.
Anyways,
he said in my coworkers were taking me seriously.
If you're a c telling me they don't want a time out.
And he said,
once the US scored the second goal,
I yelled,
what are the odds?
I'd say about a Brazilian to one
dude.
I actually wish I was there to see that you really sign up noxious.
That must've been great is then he goes,
he goes,
but then in the long run,
uh,
they ended up giving me shit because a,
as I was watching the game,
um,
I was thinking,
why,
why not have Brazil take a,
Oh,
this is,
this is a big conspiracy theory.
He goes,
but as I was watching the game,
I thought it was something that,
uh,
I'm amazed that the F F I f a
didn't arrange us to make it happen.
I was thinking,
why not have Brazil take a dive against the u s but you know,
make it look good.
And then the next year when the World Cup came around,
the interest in the US would be through the roof,
you know,
let the u s beat Brazil and then you,
uh,
you spit out a bunch of t shirts,
you split them 50,
50,
with the Brazilian,
you know,
the whole,
we kick Brazilians ass,
uh,
Brazil's acid in 15 years when everyone has forgot about the game.
That's when you make the movie.
Okay.
What do you think about the idea of bill?
Well,
I think if I read it a little bit better when it made more sense,
you think it would have worked?
Um,
yeah,
I think we beat Brazil and the u s team started,
uh,
building up,
you know,
something.
Actually,
I don't think it would have worked because those people down there takes soccer
way too seriously.
Brazil takes it really seriously,
but they're not like,
like Columbia or was it Columbia?
Like,
uh,
was it the Venezuelan team?
Somebody accidentally put the ball in their own net and the guy went home and he
got fucking machine guns,
like the fucking Saint Valentine's Day massacre,
you know?
Okay.
Um,
so no,
I don't think it would work.
I think would work in America because we don't give a fuck about soccer.
Um,
all right.
I think that's the end of the questions.
Did I have anything else here?
I'm a little disorganized.
Uh,
yeah.
All right.
How about this?
I bought a movie review and then I'm going to end this podcast because,
oh man,
I have to end it now.
This is too fucking lock.
I'll read one really quickly.
Uh,
the punisher movie review based on the marvel comic character Thomas Jane who
was in the midst,
the dream catcher and the thin red line stars is Frank Castle who was a former
green baret that becomes an FBI agent.
Castle has one last bus to make that vol stolen weapons.
And during the bus,
the son of a mob boss,
Howard St,
played by John Travolta is killed st wants vengeance son who got his son killed
and finds out the castle is one the one who caused saints son's death.
Not to spoil,
but shit happens.
And castle gets in his Camaro to fuck shit some shit up.
I give it two out of four stars.
It's a movie that tries to be a re realistic,
which is great compared to the over the top cliche acro action sequences and the
sequel.
It's definitely worth the rent or a purchasing as how it was $5 on DVD and $10
on Blu Ray at best buy or Walmart.
And there are two versions to three theatrical and the extended edition.
So this guy gives it two out of four stars basically saying the punisher is a
good rental.
All right.
And that's the podcast for this week.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
Uh,
there's going to be one more podcast.
I'm out here in New York City and then I will finally be back out in Los
Angeles,
um,
for,
oh,
maybe I'll show you.
I'll be in San Francisco.
Yeah.
Cause July 13th is a Monday and I will be doing two shows at the punchline in
San Francisco and I've yet to put those up on my site so I have to do that.
And,
uh,
the next big date I have is I'm going to be doing the comedy works in Denver,
Colorado.
I believe the dates are the 23rd to 24th and the 25th.
So,
uh,
please come out and check that out.
And if you're a fan of my radio show at the uninformed show with Joe to Rosa,
we have a new episode coming out,
uh,
this Saturday,
July 4th,
I think I said the third early earlier,
but July 4th,
I'm listen to it from nine to midnight on Xm two oh two.
I will be sending out an email blast
just to give you guys a heads up when I get the exact time.
All right,
so that's it for the podcast.
You guys all have a great week and don't take any shit from me.
Okay.
Bye Bye.
Yeah.
[inaudible].